an anxious weight
then finally rare good news
[Music]
some 2 000 people detained an
anti-government protest
set free walking evidence of state
brutality
in belarus this man wants the world to
see his bruises
after police hauled him from a taxi
they knocked on the window come out we
open the door
they simply pulled us out beat us on our
legs with a rubber stick
face down on the ground they put on gas
masks
sprayed gas to make it hard for us to
breathe we covered ourselves with
t-shirts
igor smiles as he recalls three days of
beatings in detention
it's how he copes with the horror
they came up and beat us with rubber
batons for a minute to a minute and a
half
as a farewell nothing you can do
the pain is so strong that the men just
cried
someone lost his voice we begged them to
stop
opposition to president alexander
lukashenka is reaching new quarters
typically loyal factory workers calling
on him to go
his main opponent appearing from hiding
in next door lithuania to give a
rallying cry
we need to put an end to the violence on
the streets of belarus
i call on the authorities to end this
and enter a dialogue
i ask the mayors of all cities to
organize peaceful
mass rallies in each city on august the
15th and 16th
if the president's worried by the
challenge he's not letting on
squashing rumors he may have fled but
pressure is mounting from overseas too
the eu planning new sanctions this
politician
hopeful the european parliament will
investigate the violence
we are sending very clear message to to
those who are
behaving in such a human way that their
crimes will be investigated their names
will be
will be will be known and and they will
be
you know punished by by international
law
but the beating of detainees is
galvanizing anger
this weekend's protests a test of
strength for both sides
debra haynes sky news vilnius